[Music]
hello
i'm alexander rose the executive
director here at long now
i'm joined today from british columbia
by our speaker dr suzanne simard
suzanne has developed revolutionary new
techniques for discovering the way trees
even between species
are able to articulate their needs
within the forest
welcome dr suzanne smart
hello it's an honor for me to be here my
name is dr
suzanne simard i'm a professor at the
university of british columbia
and a researcher i'm here to talk to you
today about mother trees and
how i discovered their importance in
forests
and how they contribute sort of to what
i'm calling the wisdom of the forest
so before i start i just want to
acknowledge first of all that i am
giving this talk and most of my research
is on the unseated territory
of a number of first nations here in
canada
i'm actually in nelson british columbia
right now on the unseated territory of
the tanaha
the tsarnaex and the okanagan nations
when i do my work
in vancouver which is where i teach
and where my university is um that is
the territories of the musqueam
the slaywe tooth and the squamish first
nations
in british columbia there are almost all
of the territories unseated territory so
it's very important for us
to acknowledge the land on which we live
i'm actually a settler i come from a
settler family
but i work with first nations and their
wisdom has contributed enormously to
what i'm about to tell you today um and
also to all of our livelihoods and will
be in our future and i think that you'll
you'll see that as i go through my talk
so i'm going to give you some context
like what
drove me to do the research i did my own
background
as a child of british columbia and i
grew up here
in a logging family a horse logging
family i grew up in
forests that were are called inland
rainforests
these are amazing forests they're what
you would call biodiversity hot spots in
the world
they're also hot spots for carbon
storage and they're also the source of
our clean air and our clean water
here in british columbia and it flows
all the way down through through north
america
so the value of these forests is beyond
anything we imagined even 50 years ago
now we
understand you know how crucial they are
in our global
world and the changing global world so i
grew up in these places
and my research really started from when
i was a child and it's just moved
forward in trying to understand
how they work and how we can how we we
can honor them
and their wisdom to help us to live in a
happy and healthy environment when my
family came to north america
they eked out a living and they did it
through selective harvesting
so that what that means is that they
would take out you know certain species
and certain sizes of trees
and then left the forest to regenerate
itself there was no planting back then
it was just that the the logging was
such a light touch
that the trees were able to reseed into
these small gaps created
by the harvesting and then become a
forest
it just seemed like that my grandfather
and my uncles were all part of the
forest and the
forest grew up around them and we grew
up around the forest
and so that's how i got to know it so
everything was very labor intensive and
very
very very slow and that's so important
because
as they did this work it was a very
light touch on the landscape it was very
much you know you just take what you
need and then leave the rest this is a
photo here of my grandfather and my
uncle's on what's called
it's a log boom in what was called the
skookum chuck narrows on the shoeshop
river they were regularly crushed in
these logging
adventures and they would have to break
up these log jams with dynamite they
would lose their hands their fingers
almost all of my uncles and grandfathers
and great uncles
had missing fingers it was pretty
exciting way to grow up
and so i actually followed in my
grandfather's footsteps when i was
uh in my teens you know if girls weren't
actually
allowed to go into forestry we were um
you know we were supposed to go into
nursing or education or something
and so it was kind of an unusual pathway
for me and i was really lucky
at the time that that ubc where where i
went to university
had just opened its doors to girls and i
was able to start out
doing forestry and this is me when i'm
in my early 20s working
for a logging company so that would have
been in the late 70s and then the early
80s
the whole logging practices had shifted
and they shifted from
this small scale horse logging family
operations to
big industrial clear cutting and so
that's how i started out my careers
is looking at big industrial clear
cutting which was so different than what
how i'd grown up and right now in
british columbia we're really
grappling with the fact that we only
have three percent of our iconic old
growth rainforest
left going back to my own neighborhood
my own where i grew up this is the
shoeshop river where my
grandparents the smart family had
homesteaded but it had become
a place of clear cutting as well and
that you can imagine the impact that
would have had and the changes are
cumulative and we're seeing that
signature on the landscape now
this is actually a picture taken about
15 years ago
of what our landscape looks like so i
grew up in a landscape of old growth
forests
british columbia western canada is and i
would say of the west of
of the united states as well has shifted
from a landscape of old growth forests
to a landscape of clear cuts
with only small pockets of old growth
forests that are left
there are huge implications for that
we've converted these old growth forests
to plantations
and this is what these plantations look
like clear cutting means taking away
all of the trees and then they're
replanted to one or two species
in this case douglas fir this is a
monoculture meaning one species
and then they're cultivated or weeded
and tended to get rid of all the other
or as many of the other plants as
possible to favor
these trees with the idea being that if
you get rid of the native plants
then all those resources will be
available to grow big fat trees
of course as i moved along in my career
i eventually became a researcher and one
of my jobs was to figure out how to grow
plantations
and then if there's something wrong with
them what the heck is wrong with them
and what can we do about it
and as i started working on this and at
the time in the early 90s i was working
in the
ministry of forests the government and
that was also when the mountain pine
beetles started coming through
and we started noticing that in these
plantations so this is a plantation of
lodgepole pine
in a sub-boreal spruce forest where the
beetle has specifically attacked and
killed those planted logical pines
and why is that the case well the
problem here is it was planted one
species
in a sea of a multi-species forest
and so it was like a had a target on its
back for the beetle it was exactly what
the beetle
wanted was a simplified forest that had
been weeded to grow
bigger faster lodgepole pines that were
the host of the beetle
and i've done many studies since then to
show that we have like about 50
different damaging agents in these kinds
of forests now that are basically
chewing their way through
and as climate is warming up we found
that it's getting
worse and worse i started to do some
research on what's going on in the soil
so there are big pathogens that were
killing forests and
a lot of those big pathogens attacked
big roots of old trees
but we were also noticing trees dying in
plantations of course
and so i went back to school to try to
figure out what had we done
to create this imbalance in the soil
and among these fungi that would make
the forest more vulnerable
and so i was looking at a smaller subset
of fungi mycorrhizaes
and these fungi they're mutualists that
means that they help the trees grow
they don't decay them they don't infect
them or they don't cause them to decline
and so i started studying this in our
forests the first work that i
i did on looking at connections and
communications between trees is i
started with a complex system
a simpler system would be to work with
one species but i was working with two
because i was interested in
how we were manipulating these species i
worked with three
actually i worked with douglas fir paper
birch and western red cedar
which are all native species in my
forest and
douglas fir is the one that foresters
want because it
brings top dollar paper birch is
considered a weed and so
it's actively managed against it's
actually weeded out of forests using
herbicides and
anything we can get our hands on to get
rid of that pesky plant because it's
supposedly stealing from douglas fir
resources light water and so on
and then the third species was western
red cedar which
of course is a really valuable species
for lots of reasons but into foresters
it wasn't at that time it was considered
a pesky species even though our first
nations consider it they actually call
it the tree of life
because of all of the benefits it
provides to ecosystems as well as
people but but in the forestry world at
the time it was considered a weed as
well
but i used the three species to look at
communication and connection because
they all had different roles in the
ecosystem and through many years of
studies with my students and
and others determined that throughout
our forests
throughout the world that trees depend
on these mycorrhizaes
and that these plants actually are
networked together into a single unit by
these fungi that
all of the trees all over the world with
their mycorrhizal fungi
actually are connected together we are
also able to detect
defense enzymes and how when a tree is
injured like a mother tree gets attacked
by the mountain pine beetle
what kind of messages is that tree
sending to to neighboring seedlings and
so we're able to actually detect these
enzymes that end up
in the neighboring plants and how the
the
rna and the dna is upregulated in
response to
those enzymes so that these neighboring
plants can actually upregulate and
produce their own defense enzymes as
well at the time there was a lot of
skepticism about this
i published a paper in nature that went
into what these
connections meant to the forest and
there was a lot of
skepticism that these things didn't
actually exist in nature or they weren't
important
these fungi you can't see them with the
naked eye um
even the a microscope even though you
can see them on the root tips
you can't actually see how these threads
move or travel through the soil
and so eventually we got molecular tools
where we could actually you know
identify fungi based based on their dna
sequences
and we went into a forest of douglas fir
a simple forest you know it was a native
or primary forest that means that it had
never been logged
and so we went in and we wanted to map
the fungi and the trees
in this map the circles in the fred gear
represent trees
and the bigger the circle the bigger the
tree and the darker the circle the older
the tree
so the oldest trees in this little
forest
are about 300 years old and the youngest
trees which are the little yellow
circles in the middle are about 10 years
old
and so it's a multi-age forest based on
this figure
so we call those uneven age forests and
you can see there's about 60 trees
in this forest um and then the lines
that are linking these different circles
or these trees together
are the fungal jennas or the individual
fungi
of two species that we were tracking and
these two
sister species were basically linking
all of the trees together
and the biggest oldest tree which is up
in the upper right hand corner of the
figure
was actually of the 60 trees was linked
to 47 other trees
and so it turned out that every tree was
linked to every other tree through a
series of hop skips and jumps
and so this map alone just completely
transformed how people were viewing
forests at the time which was that
trees were individuals that that
competed for resources and that
competition isn't the only thing that's
happening in these fours that there's a
lot of collaboration going on
in that collaboration one of the vectors
for that collaboration are these
mycorrhizal linkages
the one thing to notice is that these
little trees these little yellow
seedlings that you can see here these 10
year olds
when the seed falls from the old trees
these old
big old 300 year old trees the seed
falls to the forest floor
it germinates you know as soon as it
germinates it
the seed will send a hypocotyl down into
the soil which starts sending signals
to the other roots and fungi and
critters bacteria in the soil there's a
huge communication going on
a chemical communication basically they
just link into the network of the old
trees
they become part of this big woven quilt
those seedlings suddenly have a huge
resource available to them
they've got the resources of their
elders they have they also just by
having the mycorrhizaes they're able to
also access
all of the nutrients and water in the
soil that these big old trees are able
to access as well
you know it's like inheriting a large
bank account as soon as you're born
so the other thing that happens they get
mycorrhizal but they also start
receiving subsidies
from these old trees if they didn't have
these subsidies they would die
they wouldn't make it in the understory
of these old trees it's too shady it's
too dark
they can't photosynthesize enough on
their own and so it's a very dynamic
environment throughout the life of these
trees and archived in their
tree rings then is that history they
tell a story
of the stresses and the riches that come
along to a tree
throughout their lifetime eventually
these young seedlings
themselves grow up to become mother
trees themselves
and then they you know have tons of
resources they can send to their own
seedlings
well can these old trees do they nurture
all the seedlings
can it be a different species it's like
a community right with all the different
people in that community
like my little town of nelson with all
the different people you know that have
all their professions and we interact in
that very fluid way
it's the same thing in the forest with
all their specialties well it turns out
that these old trees
can recognize which ones are their own
seedlings they have
kin recognition and that they're able to
adjust
where they're sending carbon based on
the identity of their kin
and so in the process of doing that they
actually favor their own genes they
favor
their kin and that carries the line
forward in a real
in a forest if we were to look at every
species of fungi and every network there
would be
hundreds and the linkages would be so
dense and so numerous you wouldn't even
be able to
to see that it it would be just opaque
so what do we do about this other than
protesting and chaining ourselves to
trees
yes by all means let's do that but
there's we also need to figure out ways
where we can emulate some of these more
careful management practices
based on being on the land and listening
and trying to protect
those wonderful resources and all that
at the same time as protecting you know
biodiversity
carbon storage and all while climate is
changing and making it harder and harder
and harder to do that
so how can we help these forests so i
started a project
about five years ago to try to address
some of these things
called the mother tree project the basic
idea is taking that basic research
on tree communication and connection and
applying it in forestry practices
so that we can actually look after the
basic things that we need in order to
have a life on this planet
which it means protecting our forests
protecting the carbon stocks that are in
those forests the biodiversity that's in
them
and so we wanted to retain mother trees
in different
amounts and configurations with the idea
that we knew that they
were essential to regeneration and
essential to protecting
all the other creatures in the forest
and we also wanted to look at genetic
gradients because we knew
already that the rate of climate change
is so fast the velocity
is so high that trees cannot migrate as
quickly as we need them to in order to
retain
forests on our earth to retain forested
landscape
we're going to have to help them migrate
we're going to help species
and genotypes move because we've made it
too fast for them to do it on their own
i'm going to show you some of our early
results on this we focused on one
particular forest type
douglas fir because it's got this big
broad range across british columbia so
these are undergraduate and graduate
students and they are the lifeblood of
this
of this project it's a hundred year
project i'm going to be gone
well before it even reached the forest
reaches a teenage year
and so they're going to be the ones that
are carrying this into the future
this is the biggest experiment i've ever
designed it's probably one of the
biggest climate experiments in forests
in north america so we have actually a
total of 27
forests that have been treated in
different ways where we
retain mother trees in different
configurations and compare them to an
uncut
primary forest so a native forest
and then we've taken that native forest
and cut out different patches of trees
leaving these different mother trees in
different amounts and configurations so
the 60
means that we we cut out gaps of trees
and left 60
of the mother trees and thinned them
from below to try to boost their
vigor and then with the next one this 30
is we created
larger gaps in the forest and left
patches of 30
so just smaller patches this 10 is
what's known as a seed tree method it's
a very common forest harvesting method
across europe and north america where
you leave individual trees
the problem with it is that what we have
found
across british columbia anyway is that
about a third of those trees are dead
within five years
and that's part of the reasoning behind
having these 30 and 60
patches as well to protect the mother
trees from dying
from blowing over or just dying from
stress or shock
from losing its neighbors and its family
we wanted to track the biodiversity so
we measured
everything like the lichens and the
mosses the plants the trees
the small mammals the large mammals we'd
like to look at the birds
um and and also where is all the carbon
in those
ecosystems we measured you know every
stick every plant
every tree we dug our soils down to a
meter and collected soil from all those
different depths
we took them back to the lab and we
measured all the nitrogen and
carbon in those samples and we were able
to actually reconstruct the carbon
budget for our forest
so all of our 27 sites then had to be
harvested by all of our partners
which was a huge undertaking and then me
and my students went out and planted all
of our special seedlings in these
forests
and now we're going back and evaluating
how they look what the biodiversity
is so one of the things along our big
climate gradient
is that we know naturally that tree
species
richness or how many trees are there
varies and sure enough that's reflected
in our data
where and this also happens worldwide
that when you have
replete climates with with very good
climatic conditions there's more tree
species
and then as it gets drier and drier and
more harsh you have fewer tree species
and tree species richness is correlated
with
carbon but tree species richness isn't
the only thing
when we look at the full suite of
species and i'm just talking about
plants right now
all through from the top of the trees
down into the soil
this is the carbon pools in our forest
and so we have
here's our dry forest at the left hand
side of our curve and our wettest
climatic region on the far right part of
the curve
the brown part of the figure is what's
below ground
and the green part is the carbon above
ground so
here's an amazing thing is that when
you're walking through the forest
everything that you see all the trees
the plants what's on the ground
that's only half of the carbon the other
half is hidden away from site below
ground
and that is where our really stable
carbon pools are those are so
precious to us with climate change we
can take off the above ground and
and harvest it and turn it into toilet
paper but we need to make sure that that
below ground pool is really stable and
safe in the ground
so that we don't double the problem if
you just look at the raw data
what this figure here is showing is that
as you increase the number of tree
species in plantations and i'm thinking
plantations here because
keep in mind we only plant one or two
species because we're very simplistic
with our management we're always keeping
that carbon pool
low if we do that right the reason for
that is as you add more species in the
ecosystem
they start occupying different niche
spaces above ground and below ground so
above ground if you look at this
nice picture on the diagram you can see
all these different tree species with
their have
occupied different layers of the canopy
some of them are photo
synthesizing in the upper canopy some
are shade tolerant and doing it in the
lower canopy
but they're occupying or they're
accessing or acquiring
all those sun rays that are coming in
there and converting them into
photosynthate
and it's photosynthetic that drives the
whole below ground processes all the
nutrient cycle the carbon cycle
the water cycle and what's going on
below ground too as you add more species
of trees is they too
occupy different niches in the soil and
if you start taking species away you
start
basically truncating the ability of the
ecosystem to acquire resources and be
productive
and so by simplifying our ecosystems and
it doesn't matter if it's a forest
or a grassland or a cropland that when
we simplify to a few species we actually
lose these niches or we don't occupy
them and we lower the productivity of
our
of our plant communities so there's a
lesson here for
management okay now i'm just going to
talk about
one last little piece here and that is
what is the effect of leaving these old
mother trees
on regeneration and this is just a
subset of our regeneration data so this
is really talking about the ability
of the forest to recover right it's
resilience
this is looking at total density of up
to three years post-harvesting
and you can see that you know in forests
where we're intact or where we left a
lot of the mother trees
there's a lot of regen right they're
recovering really fast
as we clear cut we get less and less and
less and less
you well that seems obvious because
there's fewer trees there but there's
just fewer seed around and they're more
at risk of dying from frost
and drought and even if they do get
established the other thing here is that
the richness of species so that is
the number of species coming back also
is greater when we leave more over story
covers leaving these mother trees is not
just important for density is important
for
the diversity of the species coming back
along this
axis here the z-axis is our aridity
gradient or our climate gradient
and this is just showing that in a
really favorable environments where it's
wet
and cool that we get a lot of
regeneration
as it gets drier which is these orange
bars in front
dry hot environments it's a lot harder
so
in harsher environments either hot and
dry
or cold and dry regeneration is a lot
more difficult in those ecosystems you
need
a lot more protection so i mentioned how
our species our trees
cannot keep up with the rate of climate
change the velocity of climate change
is orders of magnitude higher than what
trees can migrate at the pace that they
can migrate great at
and so we have to help them we have to
move them around and so we've done that
in this project
and what we found first of all is that
these warmer genotypes that we as we
move them north
they're actually doing okay right it's
warmed up enough that that they're
surviving in these warmer climates
that we've created through climate
change so our ability to migrate stuff
is actually pretty darn good
the second thing i want you to notice is
in these other figures this is the
driest and hottest site
and this is the most northern site that
most northern side is the
northern limit of douglas fir okay
douglas fir is projected to actually
migrate all the way up to the yukon
as climate changes over the next century
it's going to move if it can
it's going to move but what this is
showing is that it's they're going to
need to have
protective trees in order for them to do
that so this is our 60
retention treatment and our 100
retention
and this is the clear cut and you can
see that the clear cuts are not
the survival and the height growth is
not as great
as it is under these retention
treatments how important is this
it's hugely important because if you fly
over the north of british columbia
all we do is clear-cut right that is all
we do
if you fly over the north of across the
boreal forest
all we do is clear-cut so we're actually
setting ourselves up for
a pretty tough time if we're going to be
migrating species
this is a very compelling argument for
changing the whole thing
and we need to change it quickly because
climate is changing so fast
we need to shift away from clear cutting
in the north
to partial retention so we can migrate
species so they have their mother trees
to look after them
to help them succeed in these colder and
drier climates and therefore we can
actually
keep forests alive on the ground and
productive and healthy
and able to sequester carbon and house
biodiversity
and my final point here is that keeping
these old trees around here also
mitigates fire risk
right they're not as fire prone as young
plantations are
those young plantations full of douglas
were and lodgepole pine
it's like you could throw a match in
them and they and they just go up
because they're so flammable
but old trees they have thick bark they
have deep roots they keep the forest
moisture by bringing water up from deep
down
and they cause the re the risk of fire
to go down
in a big way and we've measured that in
our project
and this just shows and i'm you don't
have to understand this whole thing but
this is just like if you look on the
blue side over here this is one of our
sites
the wettest site and it shows that clear
cutting the risk and this is just
risk of fire is higher in our clear cuts
by about double than it is where we
retain these old trees and it's because
the old trees are less
less flammable and it's also because
there's less
slash left around after after harvesting
as well
so there's multiple benefits to having
these old mother trees
for uh storing carbon for keeping
healthy forests
for having a resilient forest in the
future so let me just go through these
concluding remarks
is that our forests are under a lot of
stress they're stressed out from climate
change
and they're stressed out from how we've
managed them over the last hundred years
and this is only going to amplify in the
future and they need
our help you know we've gotten to the
point where we can't we can't just walk
away
we've got to do something to help them
migrate and be productive moving forward
and we can do that by retaining these
old tree neighborhoods
for enhancing regeneration protecting
the new seedlings coming up
housing the biodiversity and protecting
those carbon stocks
and this is going to be especially
crucial in harsher environments where
seedlings just like our babies when we
grow when they grow up in our little
human families they need our help right
um those little seedlings we're gonna
need the help of their mother trees
and so we and especially on harsher
sites where
there's there's more risks involved and
we can migrate these genotypes from from
warmer to to colder climates
as climate changes we need to do it it
can be successful
but it's going to be more successful if
we leave the old trees around
in fact we could be you know it could be
a disaster if we don't keep those old
trees around
it would be like you know creating a
like a parking lot to try to put your
kids out on it
you just don't want to do that you want
to have a nice healthy environment for
them
to be moved into and how you retain
those old trees the patterns
it's all got to be based on the land
watching the land knowing the land
seeing what's going on seeing how it's
changing that means having people on the
land
and knowing the land it means getting
out of our cities and going out and
actually being part of the management of
our forests
and finally doing experiments like what
i've done with the mother tree project
is wonderful for young people obviously
for students
um they can go be part of it and feel
like their agents have changed
i can't emphasize how important that is
but also we can go look at these
experiments and we can say okay that
worked and that didn't work and that
worked before but it doesn't work now
so we can use them to calibrate
ourselves we can use them to
create models to project into the future
and validate those models
and lastly to motivate us to change
because
when we when we can see what what what's
positive and helpful
then we can we can emulate that and
build on it
so thank you very much and i hope i hope
that this presentation was uh
enlightening um
i hope that you can see how my early
work on plant communication
and saving old mother trees is important
not just in healthy forests but how
we can use this knowledge to help us
look after our forests in the future so
thank you so much
[Music]